[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Mute Findings is a
powerful volume management tool
within Security Command Center.
It allows you to
automatically silence
findings based on
criteria you specify,
or manually silence
individual findings.
This feature is relevant for
many potential use cases.
For example, assets within
non-production environments
where some stricter requirements
may not be applicable,
recommendations to use
customer-managed encryption
keys in projects that don't
contain critical data,
when granting broad access on
a datastore which intentionally
is open to the public
and disseminates
public information,
or for findings
not relevant to
your organization
based on your
company's policies.
Muted findings don't appear by
default in the Security Command
Center dashboard.
However, they
continue to be logged
and can be accessed as needed.
There are two ways
you can mute findings.
You can create mute rules that
automatically mute findings
as they are generated, or you
can choose to mute and unmute
individual findings.
Let's see this
feature in action.
Currently we are located at
the Security Command Center
Findings tab for a
specific project.
We'll focus on a
category of findings
that are generated when
bucket logging is disabled.
Suppose we want to silence
findings within this category.
We can use the Mute Findings
feature to hide them.
As you can see, we can
select individual findings
to mute and unmute using
the Mute Options menu,
but you can also
create a mute rule
to automatically mute
findings as they are
generated based on a criteria.
First we'll give
the mute rule an ID.
Note that this rule will apply
to all findings generated
within the resource
that we have selected.
Now we'll set up the
filter by selecting
Category equal to
Bucket Logging Disabled.
After clicking Apply, we can
preview any existing findings
that match this filter.
Once this rule is implemented,
all existing and new findings
that exactly match the
filter will be hidden,
and the mute attribute for the
findings will be set to Muted.
One thing to note--
if you are creating
mute rules with the gcloud tool
or Security Command Center API,
muting existing
and future findings
are two separate operations,
so be sure to check out
the documentation for details.
After clicking Save, we'll
return to the Security Command
Center and review our findings.
Our new mute rule
has taken effect,
and we can no longer see any
findings in the Bucket Logging
Disabled category.
As mentioned, mute rules
created in the Console
will mute both existing
and future findings
that match the filter.
So let's create another
bucket to see how
future findings are handled.
We're back.
After creating a
new bucket, we can
see that no additional
findings in the Bucket Logging
Disabled category are visible.
However, findings that
are muted are not deleted,
and new findings that match mute
rules continue to be logged.
As such, they can be viewed
by selecting More Options
and choosing Include
Muted Findings.
Now we can see the muted
findings, including
the additional
finding that was just
created for our new bucket.
The Include Muted
Findings option
is useful when you
are trying to review
all findings for any
audit or compliance needs.
Now if we would like to review
only the muted findings,
we can apply a filter--
Mute equals Muted.
In these muted findings, we can
see when a finding was muted
and who muted the finding, which
we can use for audit purposes
at any time.
We can also configure
any notifications
that we've set up
to exclude updates
from any new or existing
findings that are muted.
Mute rules can be managed
from the Mute Settings page.
On this page, we
can view our rules,
edit them, and delete them.
When we delete a
rule, it doesn't
unmute any findings
that were muted
in the past as a
result of this rule,
but future findings
will no longer be muted.
Congratulations.
You're now equipped to
use the Mute Findings
feature in Security Command
Center as a customizable volume
management tool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]